[Musik]
beim 1
ich hoffe euch ist gut ich hab heute
endlich wieder die bezaubernde mache
dabei das geht alles gut ich weiß ich
hoffe dabei ich muss sehr gut gehen weil
du gerade das und alex muss auf jeden
fall gibt's heute ein neues video von
uns beiden und wir haben uns das
spektakuläre sein verhalten also für
mich wird das denke ich mega peinlich
also wirklich eine tendenz die sie
aufgenommen habe und für sie wird so
cool und war war es glaube ich so vor
einem jahr oder so voll im trend
da hat man so eine aufzuzählen was also
dass dinge wir haben ja beide gerade
outfit an irgendwie komme ich gerade bei
diesem video extrem vielen neben dem
bildschirm und man ist eigentlich immer
guck doch mal hier sehr gut verständlich
auf jeden fall wie der name schon sagt
mir sagt das eigentlich wir 1000 heute
unsere auftritte praktisch als wir haben
jeder drei outfits oder zwei outfits
mitgebracht und der andere fragen
präsentieren
ich denke das hat jeder verstand ich
weiß auch nicht was ich dazu noch sagen
soll was man versteht ihr denkmal sofort
wenn wir jetzt anfangen ein kleines
licht auf seine hose aber wenn man das
führung hält kann er seine hose seinem
handy wissen alleine rechts liegen
sie haben wohl gar nicht eingeladen
lasst doch nach oben da und vorsang geht
jetzt schon keine ahnung macht einfach
und ich würde sagen wir machen es nicht
sehr klug wer anfängt
was seine aussage ich kann kein
stückwerk
das ist auch ein glücksspiel verfallen
an ihrem ersten auftritt wenn ich zeigen
dass es auch so sein
mit fünf anderen bin ich mal gespannt
für mich wird deutlich abgebremst ich
würde ich nein sieht auch für einfach
cool aus dem tempel nicht so richtig
wollte er nun aber mit nicht nur nec
inflation und leid empfinden besonders
trendy machen mädchen schon natürlich
habe auch eine weiße leder mit der
qantas richtig cool machen verein etwas
verdienen weil sie nicht rumlaufen
garantiert ohne spart so ich bin dran
ich muss sagen geh mal dahin und suchte
das sieht aber eine stylishe aus er
sitzt noch nicht ab auch noch mal eine
haft noch mal deine haare komplett ohne
dicke ist wendy southgate ich musste nur
zweimal die latte das ist design von mir
weil in den wahlkreis glockner die
letzte messe noch mal wechseln
meine ich sag mal so das einzige konzert
soll es die kurse
[Musik]
ich finde wenn er die haare machen aber
die haare aus ich will dass sie
eigentlich coole art wenn ich lache
geben wenn ihr dass sie für was sie
drunter hast also ehrlich wenn ich mir
so ein bisschen draußen
also ich finde das habe ich schon mal
besser geht für dich als du vermisst
dann zeige ich euch mal dass sie als
mädchen doch wäre schön dass es jetzt
sogar ein luchs katalonier eingangslied
kosten
und ja wer auch bürger finde eine
[Applaus]
unwichtig ob es jetzt durch ein anstieg
von ihr verstanden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich sehe aus wie ein baby als
wirklichkeit
so jetzt würde ich mich wieder
einigermaßen bohlen also eigentlich habe
ich schon meine aus überstanden
jeder freut sich an schwimmer hoch her
also das ist das andere
aber es folgten ihr könnt aber
bewertungen kommentare von 0 bis 10
wie steht ihr zu diesem outfit also 0
bis 10 kommentare oder das davor wasser
besser als wir gespannt was davor war
echt hat mit zusagen wirklichkeit und
hat jetzt und jetzt catalana also für
das nicht outfit würde ich mindestens
zwei zeugen leicht nehmen lässt sich der
zeitung
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich werde so auf die idee kommen wieder
vertragen und männer zwischen gebildet
und das fest des jahres für supermann
rings drauf machen sich oft so wie das
jetzt so könnte das auch in
modemagazinen seinen 32
sachen gibt und so zeug aber was mit
solchen hier eingelassen
das sagt mit dem video hat euch gefallen
hat dann nach oben da lag bei marie mal
bei instagram vorbei hier kurz
eingeblendet und wir sehen uns dann
sagen wir sehen uns von morgen wieder
morgen um 14 uhr
haut rein